أظهر فيروس كورونا في المستشفيات في جميع أنحاء إسرائيل
عدم مبالاة
بالدين أو المعتقد العرقي ، فالأطباء
والممرضات على خط المواجهة يتشاركون نفس
الحياد في المعركة ضد كوفان.
19 الأطباء والممرضات العرب وقفوا
جنبًا إلى جنب مع زملائهم اليهود
.  لا يهمني
من هو لماذا يسألون هل يجب أن
أعتقد أننا جميعًا اليهود والمسلمين
نعطي ما هو ضروري لكل مريض
بغض النظر عن الدين
والمعتقد العرقي وهذا واجبنا علينا القيام
به بشكل صحيح دون الاتصال
بأي شيء آخر د.  جميل حسن هو
رئيس وحدة الفيروسات التاجية في
مركز EFM الطبي الحلال في كادينا ، وهو واحد من العديد من
المهنيين الطبيين العرب في
المناصب العليا في إسرائيل ، حيث تتعامل
طوال الوقت مع أشياء لم نكن نعرفها
ولا نعرف هذا الفيروس على وجه الخصوص نحن
لم يسبق أن رأيت فيروسًا ينتشر حقًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم
وأعتقد أننا استعدنا جيدًا في هذا البلد
، لقد خلقت الوحدة الطبية بعضًا من
لحظات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، اثنان من المسعفين
أحدهما يهودي والآخر مسلم يصلي
جنبًا إلى جنب خلال استراحة قصيرة
عربي  طبيب يحضر توراة يهودية
إلى وحدة الفيروسات التاجية
لليهود للصلاة
، مقطع فيديو جديد يظهر الطاقم الطبي في أقنعة
كأبطال فقط ليكشف أن هؤلاء
الأطباء والممرضات عرب يصفونهم
بأنهم جزء لا يتجزأ من دولة
إسرائيل
[موسيقى]
بطبيعتها تلك الرسالة  هل استهدف
رئيس الوزراء السياسي بنيامين نتنياهو
مرارًا السياسيين العرب في إسرائيل
ووصفهم بأنهم مؤيدون
للإرهاب جرد قانون دولته القومية
العربية من  atus كلغة رسمية
ومكرسة في القانون ولكن
اليهود فقط لديهم الحق في
تقرير المصير في إسرائيل ،
نعم في أوائل أبريل عندما
احتاج نتنياهو إلى السياسيين العرب لتمرير
حزمة مساعدات بقيمة 25 مليار دولار لمواجهة فيروس كورونا ،
لم يكن هناك أي إظهار للامتنان يقول
المشرع العربي ألماتي  هو نفسه طبيب ، هذه
السياسة عنصرية العرب يشكلون حوالي
20٪ من سكان إسرائيل ، هناك 20٪
من الممرضات في البلاد وما يقرب
من نصف الصيادلة الإسرائيليين وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة والباحث في
hiya diode بالإضافة إلى 17٪ من
أطباء الدولة  من العرب ، لدينا
أفضل الأطباء في المستشفيات الإسرائيلية
يعملون معًا بأشياء رائعة من
اليهود والأطباء على حدٍ سواء وهم يكافحون
في خط المواجهة ضد
فيروس كورونا العديد من هؤلاء الأطباء الذين يأتون
من هنا يمنحون كارا أحيانًا
تسمى قرية الأطباء حسن ماريا
هي  يقول مدير المدرسة ثنائية اللغة
هنا إنها المكان الوحيد في
العالم الذي يأتي فيه الطلاب اليهود إلى
العرب  قرية لدراسة القرآن كم
هو أفضل من الكورونا هذه الأزمة ما
فعلته هو إزالة عوائق
القوالب النمطية التي ينظر الناس إلى
شخص ما ويرونه كما لو كانوا في صندوق
يخرجونه من صندوقه
حسن هو عربي  سواء كان مسلمًا أم
مسيحيًا ، هل هو مثل هذا أو مثل هذا ،
فقد أصبح بعض طلابه السابقين
أطباء ، إنه مجال يقول فيه إن
التقدم يعتمد على
الاحتراف وقليلًا آخر نيك جوردون ، من
الواضح أن هذا التغيير مرحب
به ، لم يحدث هذا التغيير للتو
بل جاء  من تغيير في فهم
كل من العرب واليهود ، إنه
تغيير لكلا الجانبين ، لا يمكنك
إحداث تغيير حقيقي من جانب واحد فقط ، إنه
خطاب عام ، إنه خطاب
حقيقي يقول إن الجميع هنا يجب أن يكونوا متساوين
، وقد تسارعت أزمة فيروس كورونا.
هذا الخطاب في وقت
الحاجة الطبية الكبيرة ، لكن التقدير
عبر المجتمع الإسرائيلي مجرد
عابر أو يمكن أن يثبت أنه دائمًا.
وحدة تقدير لمكابي ، أحد
مزودي الرعاية الصحية الوطنيين في إسرائيل ،
سترى أن الشخص الموجود داخل جهاز الاختبار ليس
مضطرًا إلى ارتداء أي حماية ، فالوحدة
نفسها هي حمايته
الآن بشكل عام في هذه المرحلة لإجراء
اختبار هنا لديك  لكي تظهر
بعض الأعراض ، لا أظهِر أي
أعراض لفيروس كورونا ، لكن لأرى كيف
يعمل هذا ، سأنتقل من خلال اختبار فيروس كورونا ،
الجزء الأول هو فحص الحلق
غير
المريح والآن لا يهم مستنقع الأنف
أنه يعطيني  خيار اليسار أو
اليمين
غير مريح ولكن تم القيام به ،
فهذه هي في الأساس
إصدارات محمولة أكثر مما رأيناه للتو إذا كان
هناك تفشي أو نقطة ساخنة في
مبنى معين أو حتى منزل معين ،
يمكن إعداد أحد هذه الإصدارات مباشرة
خارج هذا بشكل واضح  يمكن أن يحمل
شخصًا واحدًا يزن حوالي 15 رطلاً ، بينما من
الواضح أن هذا الشخص أكبر قليلاً
ويمكن أن يخضع للاختبار على كلا الجانبين مع وجود
مساحة متساوية لشخص ما على كرسي
متحرك ليصعد ويختبرك